Well, good evening and welcome to disciple making
101.
I've been nervous all week long because last week we had 207 people
come and take notebooks and people said
how do you give yourself a hand? Good job your your back. The
nervous part was how many would come back on
the next week? I said if we have 60 it was it's a
huge failure, but but you're here and
I don't know what the math is, but it's a pretty good showing so we're
gonna go ahead and get started last week.
I made a huge mistake. I
prepared and put in and had put
in all your notebooks a magnifying glass and the
purpose of the magnifying class is not to assist
the elderly with seeing the small text. All
right. It's a an object lesson that
says that this disciple making
vision is God's big vision. And so what
we're doing is simply putting a magnifying glass on
it so that we can see is what God has for us as a church.
And so but if it helps you see the
text when that's okay too, so
Let's get started. I want to share with you that one of the most important things that
we have to learn is about the disciple making pathway what
that means is that the things that we're already doing
like worship service and we have our
equipping groups and you know about those in our community groups. How many
of you just for knowledge sake
how many of you are already Faithfully attending a
community group. All right. So look at that. See
that's a great sign and I'm not surprised that you're here
Community groups are kind of the incubator for
relationships that could become a micro
groups or disciple making relationships what we're
going to be focusing on.
Is a moving people up this
pathway so that they could get to the sweet sweet spot
of discipleship, which is micro groups. Now
we are actually and I know
I sprung this on you last week, but we were actually doing
experiment with micro groups every Wednesday
night and some of you are already meeting
in your micro groups, you're like that. We don't really need that instruction piece for
going right to the group. But but this
is the pathway and I want us to all become familiar with it
because the staff is planning on working
at being intentional about moving people from
One station to the next they will
come initially to worship service and they'll
hear good preaching and good music. But that
is a what's odd about that. Is that
everybody sits where you're sitting now pointing the same direction and
the lights are down. It's kind of like a movie theater. It's not a
great spot for making relationships. So we want to go from the
worship service to the community.
Group and again another open group, but what
you're going to see here is they've all
got a purpose, but the purpose is
this.
People can come to the large group and be
fairly Anonymous and frankly some people like that.
I'm not going to have you raise your hand because you probably wouldn't anyway, but
if I said how many of you prepared prefer anonymity there's
a lot of people who come say, you know,
I don't
I'm not ready to commit I just want to come and I just want to
kind of get a feel for the church. Well, that's where you come. It's
a precise place well-timed. The
the speaker is knowledgeable has
been studying a long time. But he's the only one who speaks
as a matter of fact, don't try this
on Sunday. But if you stand up during the sermon raise your
hand and ask a question the Usher will see
you out. Okay? That's just a warning. All right, don't try me
on that. All right, but at the community groups, it
kind of goes from common language.
All right to a casual and now you're the
you have the clarity of being able to ask a
follow-up question like or you have the clarity of
being able to answer a question or comment on
something that you think the Lord might be teaching you through the
passage, but then what happens over here in our
sweet spot is now we're we're
having to customize.
For example, Jesus spoke to the
four or five thousand at the feeding of the four 5,000
also at the Beatitudes in the large group The also
spoke in the community to the disciples, but
then over here with his three or
five Peter James and John, what did he say to Peter at
the at the breakfast? He said Peter do
you love me?
So you see how you go from a common
to kind of a Clarity to now we have a customized
question and you'll be able to do that
in your micro groups other things that we'll do
is that we'll learn about whoops. Hang
on somebody's gonna teach me how to do this.
whoops
There we go. So there it is again. We're just
gonna change colors. How's that sound?
Over here we can have relationships.
We can have transparency.
Transparency would be able to say hey guys. I need you to pray
for me because I'm having a difficult time at work this
week and to explain exactly what that difficult time looks
like. And so that now you're being open and honest with people that
you can trust. So what else can we
have we have intimacy?
My first discipleship group had gotten so
close that I could look at the eyes of
the person in my discipleship group and tell whether they
were full of the Holy Spirit or grieved with the Holy Spirit and it
was odd and you just could see whether they
were full of restlessness or whether they were
full of joy in peace. And that's exactly what will
happen as we begin to grow closer in
intimacy and eventually accountability.
And accountability is something that you may
have experienced this week. You might not know this. If you're a
participant I ask your leader to send you a personal text this
week just by a raise of hands. Haven't you
got a text from your micro group this week? All right.
Okay way to go. I'm proud of you guys. This is how it
works. Okay, so
So over here you as far
as experiences go you you're seeing.
Um when I come on Sunday mornings at at 9
o'clock, I'll walk right down this Middle Island trying to find my wife
and and I'm kind of like hey good to
see you good to see you but I never stop and say how was
your week this week? Right? That's really not
the place for that and frankly.
Sometimes I don't want to know how your week was right? We're not
there for that reason. But but over
here you're heard now, maybe during
prayer requests maybe during a question
and answer time people know where you are and you can
be a little bit more vocal about what's happening. But then over
here you're known.
And that is people can see by the
look on your face where you are and if there needs to be a follow-up question,
or maybe just somebody to sit by because you're known. Okay, so
you see I want you to see how this continues to
go from common.
All right, which Pastor John and anybody
who preaches thinks? How can I share a word
from God's word that everyone can hear the brand
new Christian as well as the Christian who's been here
for a very long time one of
my very first on I first became a pastor and this
was back in 1989. There was a man
by the name of ethyl Neff and Ethel was 77
years old and he had been a southern baptist for over 60 years
and I was his 29 year old pastor.
And I thought to myself nothing to tell
this man, right? But so when you're preaching on
Sunday as Sunday, you've got this common language that just
about everybody can appreciate but then again
you have you can clear it up for a
more specific audience in your community group, but then
you can customize it for a specific person
in your micro group. So
hopefully what you're seeing here
is that
There there is a significant difference that
in fact, the rule is like this the larger the
crowd the harder it is to find Transparency intimacy
and and
frankly accountability and and there's
nothing wrong with the larger crowd because some people
need to come in and kind of to be anonymous and
they feel a little bit more willing to
come into a larger crowd because they know that nothing's going to be required of
them. How did you feel lesser? Can I said okay, we're all going
to get into micro group and you're like, oh
yelch
Right because because now you know, there's going to
be more required of you than just sitting and looking
in the same direction. So there's a difference and I hopefully you're seeing
the changes because the smaller the
crowd like a micro group for example or one-on-one
the more opportunity you
have for transparency intimacy and accountability.
And so these again this is our sweet
spot and this is what we're practicing and this is
what we're working on. I ask you to repeat after
me last week and I'm going to do it again. These are the essentials of
a good disciple making experience intentional leader.
You guys haven't even have to beg you and I'm so thankful relational environment.
And reproducible process reproducible process. So
what we're going to be doing.
In just about 10 minutes is we're
going to break into our micro groups some of you this is your first
night. And so I'm gonna have you meet me
down here so that I can help you find a leader and get into a
micro group, but we're this is
an experiment. This is a micro group experiment and I'm
going to give you a couple of discussion questions and you're going to
get to know people in your group and I can promise this is what's
going to happen.
Over the course of these next 14 weeks.
You're not going to just become more comfortable in
your group. You're going to become known.
You're going to have a customizable question that you can follow up on
and I can guarantee you that you're going to feel a connection to
that group that you did not have when you
first came in here. And that's just a 14 week
experiment when you really get into the lives
of one another in a genuine micro group experience and you're
going through what God is teaching you on a
daily basis in his word and you're praying for one. Another
with real needs. I can promise you this your
group will come together in ways that you
could not possibly imagine. I got another
text from Keith Skittle if you were here
last week Keith hit me up in the in the lobby
and in my last church, and he says I got some questions
And we met for lunch and by the end
of the lunch I said you need to be discipled and we started meeting
on Tuesday mornings and just this week Keith called me
and he says hey.
I like to come up there to Oklahoma and see you. He
said because you made such a big impact on my life. Now.
What he doesn't know is that I was
kind of in the way the Holy Spirit was doing the work right? I
just got to be a part of the process and everyone
here. If you'll believe me that God
wants you to experiment with being an intentional
leader and creating a micro group and then
investing your lives in that micro group in a relational
environment. Then I can promise you you're going to experience the
exact same kind of blessing because this is God's big
Vision. All right with that.
I want to show you something that happened before I got here. All right,
this is Henderson Hills vision statement. You guys know it it says
our vision is to glorify God by the coming a
hub for what and all ages disciple
making movement. So God has
called us to be a part of a church that
is a hub for an all ages disciple making
movement and then
Later, one of our values is intentional disciple
making what that means is we
share the gospel read and teach others
to obey Jesus commands. Now, you're going to see this theme coming
out in everything we talk about for the rest of the
night. Now the elders and Pastor John
worked very hard on this and gathered some people together so that
we could get this precisely the way we want to and look
what's happening here. Okay. This is not just a vision statement, but
now we have a definition of disciple.
Someone shaped by the word of God.
Someone Overjoyed by the gospel. Someone submitting
to the Holy Spirit demonstrating love to
others investing in God's kingdom and making disciples
of Jesus. So look look
at the person to your right to your left. Okay?
These are people.
Whom God has selected to be a part of their churches
vision for the future.
Now I gotta tell you that's pretty exciting to me.
I'm serious. Okay. I don't know how your job
went today. Mine was pretty hectic because I
was getting ready for a big meeting.
Um, but some of you you might
be thinking, you know, I just do the same thing every day and it's not
that big a deal I'm telling you right now God is calling you to
to something so profoundly powerful that
it will literally change your life and
the lives of those who you invest in Forever For
Eternity and you'll begin to
experience what it means to be shaped by God's word and Overjoyed by
the gospel and submitting to the Holy Spirit. Remember
a minute ago. I said I could see in the face of those
who I was attending whether they had grieved the Holy Spirit or
whether they were full of the Holy Spirit and you'll get
to know someone that way and someone will get to know you that way and that is the
place you want to be. Okay, so that's the
church's definition and now let's talk a little bit about the book.
In your folder you have
you don't have the book? Okay, the
book is called investing in a few it's written
by Craig Etheridge and it's a very brief read 12
chapters. And this week was
talking about the end product now in product
is this term that says we will
eventually get to a place where we have provided.
The end product. Well, the end product of
discipleship is what this chapter is about and our writer
says that this is men and women.
This is a disciples are men and women who will follow Jesus
and grow to be like him and carry
on his work.
So what we're going to be learning to do together in a
relational environment with micro group
of mutual people holding it one another
and intimate accountability. We're going to learn how to
be more like Jesus. We'll study
the word of God together individually and then
we'll gather together once a week or how often you
group your group meet decides to me and we'll discuss.
Okay. What? What did you learn this week in God's
word. And what did you like about this verse right here. What
did you highlight that you wanted to share in our micro group?
And so we will be studying God's
word together. So that why we will
grow to be like Jesus and then eventually carry on
his work. We'll be developing lifelong spiritual disciplines.
I just named four. There are more.
prayer
prayers like breath in and out
all day.
It's not just a breathing at the end of the day. It's breathing
out all day long learning how
to pray prayers of praise and prayers of accountability and prayers
of confession prayers of Thanksgiving prayers of need prayers of
Praise all those kinds of prayers. You'll learn how to do that within
the context of your micro group, but also Bible engagement
You will be studying God's word together individually and then
coming back together and Reporting what God shared with you. You say
well what if you didn't do your work well?
You'll feel the accountability of those who studied and
you didn't you say well that sounds awful.
Almost as awful is not studying God's word.
All right. So, I mean there's a reason why we want to do this and
so one of the things I love is in
in the micro groups that I've participated in.
The Holy Spirit Will Enlighten Believers to
see things in God's word that I might not see when they
share those things. Then I get to experience the joy of what they've learned
as has been given to them by the Holy Spirit.
And then I get to share what God taught me that they might not have heard
and so it becomes by God's design kind of
a cumulative effort and a communal
growth that they can only be appreciated in
a micro group community. So so Bible
engagement whether that's memorizing God's word
together studying God's word together hearing God's word.
You'll be able to comment on what you've heard maybe preached or in
a podcast and it's just it's just a wonderful place
to experience the engagement of God's word genuine
Christian Community. I don't have to share
with you any examples of that or lifestyle of angelism.
How many of you and I didn't ask this question? It's not
on my notes.
How many of you have asked a Christian brother or sister to
pray with you that you would have an opportunity to have
a gospel conversation with someone anybody ever
prayed say there's somebody I need to talk to like that anybody. Go
ahead. Yeah. See that is a perfect example.
Not only are you going live with
the opportunity for accountability. I need to
talk to my neighbor.
Pray with me that I'll have the courage and then when your neighbor
gets out and goes out to the mailbox, what's going to happen?
You like guys this is it. This is my opportunity say hey
what's going on? So anyway, this is
what we're doing. We're learning these lifelong spiritual
disciplines. Why?
This is the end product so that we would be obedient to
the commands of Jesus and experience full
participation in a community of
Jesus disciples. That's the end product
according to our author which boils us down to what I
believe should be our
simple to learn definition of what it means to be a disciple. All
right. What is a disciple one who is
following Jesus?
But not just following Jesus but actually being changed
by Jesus. This is the transformation piece. All
right, therefore if anyone be in
Christ, he is a what a new creation new creature.
The old is gone the newest come
then you read through the rest of that chapter you
get down to verse 21 says for he who knew no
sin became sin for us that we might become the righteousness of
God in him. We're transforming into
His Image, we're becoming more and more like him. We're not just following
him. We're being changed by him. And what is
the last piece of this definition and we're committed
to the mission of Jesus and that's disciple making
and that's why you're here. So this is
a definition that I would look for you to learn why say
you're not trying to try to trick us into some sort
of
I don't know.
Class Seminary class something. No. It's as
simple as knowing where we're going.
Okay.
I don't know these very well. So you guys are going to have to help me
to fail to plan
is to plan.
To fail. All right, if you don't know where you're headed, if
you don't know what the Target or the goal is, you'll not know when
you're even getting close to it. But if if you're involved
in a microgate group, you're Holy One Another accountable you
you're moving closer together. Not only intimately in
relationship but intimately in a relationship with Jesus, then
you're saying this is what it means to follow Jesus.
And this is what it means to be transformed or
Changed by Jesus and this is what it means to be committed
to the mission of Jesus disciple making so please learn
this. We'll be going over it and over
it. This is only our second week and you're saying oh this all like seems like
such new material. Come on the third. I mean on the 8th or
9th week, you'll hear it that many times and start becoming familiar to
you.